let's talk about what's going on in uh
over in europe because of our poor
leadership companies are overwhelmed
with inquiries for nuclear bunkers in
switzerland and reporting shortage of
materials following ukraine invasion
since the 1960s every swiss municipality
had to build nuclear bunkers for
residents residents are now contacting
specialist companies to build or
renovate shelters the bunkers are being
viewed in a new light since russia's
invasion of ukraine
what switzerland needs is 200 gallon
propane tanks for the impending russian
oil embargo
under uh donald trump no new wars
now um under joe biden
bunkers
nuclear bunkers nuclear bomb
congratulations i guess you vote we went
from if it saves one life to how bad can
world war three be yeah yeah exactly i
mean if it's for a good cause
if it's if it saves one life we'll vote
for joe biden one of the most corrupt
individuals to ever serve government and
then anthony blinken and and the the
defense secretary of
loy austin are like posing with zolansky
who's the defense secretary what's her
name lloyd austin lloyd austin's a guy
yeah
like
how much more direct involvement in
ukraine are we going to get
oh it seems like we're going in i i
don't i don't know for sure but you know
i i think it's good look
vladimir putin
russia they already believe they're at
war with nato there's no
it it is in my opinion
ignorant propagandized americans who
don't understand this point do you think
that vladimir putin is sitting there
saying i sent my troops into ukraine and
they're fighting nato tanks and fighter
jets
that that's just ukraine or do you think
he's like i'm at war with nato
he's a war with nato all of the weapons
even the people
do you think vladimir putin is sitting
there watching american veterans
fighting in ukraine and he goes well
those are just volunteers or is he
saying america
nato countries are sending people
they're coming in they're being armed by
nato
well i'll put it this way when
we found out that non-government russian
citizens purchased forty six thousand
dollars worth of facebook ads related to
the 2016 presidential 4600 i'm sorry 4
600 take out a zero wow so even better
helps me make my point even better when
that occurred and we learned that
there were respectable figures in
american politics saying that that was
an act of war by russia against the
united states of america well the only
answer is world war iii three
obviously yeah let's uh just just blow
it all up it's funny that like the
people who always tell us to go to war
are telling us to go to war now i mean
there must be a good reason i mean
you'll you'll notice something none of
this is going to the u.n
all these like accusations of war crimes
and all of these other accusations
whatever none of it's going to the u.n
because they know i mean they already
know they tried to get a condemnation of
russia and the rest of the world was
like no
we know what you're up to
like sticking a bunch of troops in
artillery on the border of a country of
a sovereign country well that's you know
shocked when they invade to destroy the
border defenses yeah i mean that's what
uh putin said when he invaded is he's
like look you're creating an untenable
security situation on my border and
technically by international law i
believe that justifies going in
you can't have terrorists on somebody's
border and and expect them to take it
i mean israel and saudi arabia do it
and that makes for a very awkward
situation
i think the main reason that the
democratic establishment has been
screaming russia for so long is they
know that putin is like one of the one
guy in in europe that won't fall in line
that they've got everybody bending the
knee
to
the new plans for their economic block
except for russia yeah well and when you
can try to when you can successfully
convince a large portion of the american
population that the presidency
is
under the control of the russian
government any time the president
doesn't try to step up uh aggressive
acts with russia they can claim that
it's just evidence that he's bought and
sold by them so and remember when we
opposed the iraq war we were called
terrorist sympathizers and wait for the
midterms to come in
anybody who opposes our actions in
ukraine is going to be called a putin
sympathizer exactly so i'm ready you
know it's not my first rodeo and and
back then they said
you don't care about freedom we need to
fight for freedom now they go we need to
protect our democracy it's just
more meaningless buzz phrases we are
protected by securing our borders
bringing manufacturing back focusing on
our infrastructure our roads are
crumbling our bridges are crumbling we
need clean water and places uh in small
cities all over this place we got bad
pipes instead it's just like uh can we
send a billion dollars to ukraine again
yeah that's what our labor is good for i
guess to go so that's the other thing
too it's like if our money is funding
this do the people behind it really
matter if we're if they're piloting
drones even like at what point it
doesn't matter who the person is behind
it it matters who's funding it
yeah yeah absolutely i think there's one
in which case uh nuclear nuclear bunkers
world war iii everybody that's the
ballet is what can the u.s fund in
illegally in ukraine and that's why it's
like we can't get directly involved but
we can do land lease and we can send
you know military experts and advisors
and this is this is what's ridiculous if
if i'm watching a dude throw rocks at me
all right am i going to be like well
technically or i'll put this way if ian
is throwing rocks at me and sheamus is
handing him the rocks am i going to be
like sheamus is not involved in this
hold on a second no i didn't tell him to
do that with the rocks but he didn't
tell me not to no i was just passing
rocks to ian ian goes sheamus give me
rocks and you're like you got it buddy
and then i'm like i'm only at war with
ian no sheamus is doing nothing wrong
the nazis declared war on the united
states because they were giving weapons
to the british as they were the germans
were already at war with the british and
then they're like okay enough's enough
can you please stop first they tried to
i think they started syncing stuff with
you both so that's kind of how they
announced their a war but yeah if you
lend lease to someone's enemy they're
gonna look at you as an enemy for sure i
just don't think putin is looking at
global domination no he's not any
intention of jesus
he just wants he doesn't want ukraine to
become a nato country because it means
he's got artillery on his front doorstep
i mean you saw that explosion
yeah i know he's got enough problems
already but you know he doesn't need one
more um you know it was that explosion
that happened that was like closer to
moscow than kiev
yeah what was that about there was some
explosion at the fuel depot or something
uh
yeah he's got latvia in estonia their
nato countries already on his border
and you know one other thing notice they
had the worst coveted lockdowns in the
world like you could not get a job if
you were not vaccinated russia no the
baltic states
lithuania and stuff and like people had
to basically develop a black market and
this is what i keep saying it's
geopolitics that's fueling the uh the
lockdowns it's like
based on how much the the you you us
powers want people to bend the knee
uh to them is is how deep the lockdowns
are going i think it has a lot to do to
do with oil is my camera broken yeah
apparently my camera's that's weird
because it works over here i can't see
you well this one works hey look we have
a map of uh uh of europe while i top of
estonia
obs has given us is on the fritz axis
and allies here we go that's why i love
that game but i think i think you know
we talked about it before oil has a lot
to do with it um ukraine is it is it is
there's a transport for oil it's not the
camera because the clam cameras
it's clearly working right now it's just
obs scenes crap that on us for some
reason we'll have to make like
emergency backup scenes we just don't
have uh emergency backups for the right
one i wonder why that happens
these things are
all a part of grown up things happen
yeah but uh anyway the question is will
vladimir putin use nukes and do we need
nuclear bunkers
he's not gonna use nukes because once he
uses nukes he knows he's lost the war i
mean he becomes uh he he becomes a
pariah state
yeah
russia would be taken apart by the
global community if he fired nukes
that's not it's purely a scare tactic
i disagree i think he could uh use a 100
kiloton bomb on kiev and no one will do
anything about it and they're already
they're already they've already been
economically isolated people have
already said he actually has no interest
in kiev briansk was where the explosion
happened
brienne's how do you spell that one
b-r-y-a-n-s-k
bryansk
oh yeah look at that
so what is that about
no idea there are also a string of uh
food plants exploding do you guys see
that also yeah i heard about that very
bizarre and plane crashes at food plants
so i
you know people talk about supply chain
disruptions what we're really in as a
trade war and this is the one
like really
digging critique you can make of trump
as he thought he could just renegotiate
trade deals and not
disrupt the geopolitical order because
trade deals are diplomatic deals and he
saw it himself right all of a sudden
china's broke and they can't pay for
something so he had to give them some
deal in order for them to have the money
to pay off something else and now it's
like their their economy is crumbling
you know you had the default and
everything so what we're really seeing
is
the entire geopolitical order is
starting to crumble and it needs to
reset
not the great reset
but it needs to reset yeah it's
something i called out earlier today i
think if we prevail you're going to have
a lot of billionaires bankrupt or
imprisoned by 2030.
what do you mean we prevail what is that
exactly the new media people the elon
musk you know elon musk is like the
future and i don't mean that as a
suck-up i mean like he realizes what are
the new technologies what are the new
trends where we can really go into the
next generation into 2050 like he
believes global warming is real but he
has like concrete engineering ways to
actually get past it he believes in
nuclear whatever whereas you have this
old guard which is like the wef people
who honestly believe like genocide is
how you stop global warming like it's
like you ever saw a movie moonraker with
with the james bond movie moonraker it's
like humanity's poisoning the planet i
have to kill them all and repopulate the
planet i mean it's
pretty much like
king's men as well here do you want us
you want to switch it to my camera real
quick i can try and see if uh what the
heck is this the uh the scene was
removed that's what happened so it
accidentally got deleted wow so uh we've
been using it successfully yeah so it's
it's not there we can't re-add it while
we're currently live regarding climate
change you can pull the carbon dioxide
out of the air deposit it onto like
carbon pollutants not out of the air out
of the water and this is fascinating if
you
make water acidic
it will bubble up the carbon dioxide and
water as we know from soda water is a
great dissolver of carbon dioxide so
what you do and they're starting to do
this
explore with naval ships so they can
produce their own fuel
is they pump in sea water they separate
it into acid they make part acidic part
alkaline sea water the acidic sea water
bubbles up the carbon dioxide and then
they can synthesize that carbon dioxide
back into fuel it's called syn fuel and
the kicker is
it costs about three dollars a gallon to
manufacture it you've got a carbon
negative
way of manufacturing gasoline you could
solve the whole world fuel problem and
global warming at the same time what
will happen is we'll start competing
with the trees we'll be pulling so much
carbon out of the water and the air that
right exactly we'll have to
calibrate to keep it at 350. is this a
theoretical technology or this exists
this exists and there's papers in it i
was reading about it it's it's
it's it's only a matter of scaling it to
be cheap enough you know they said you
can do this on a naval aircraft carrier
for about three dollars a gallon if you
did it on the shore you could probably
get it cheaper because you don't have to
make everything you know portable or
whatever but the idea is just in the
naval situation then you don't have to
constantly go fuel up at port you could
be out your aircraft carrier
indefinitely like a nuclear submarine or
something
there's also a technology called uh uh
microfragmentation that you can do with
coral where you take coral you shatter
it into a bunch of different pieces and
you set them all near each other i fixed
it and then they all start to grow
together
to regrow coral reefs sort of build new
ones on other planets the technology
with iron fertilization to regrow the
plankton in the oceans we're there to
heal the earth we're pulling the plastic
out
absolutely there's so much tech out
there and that's what bugs me is like
all this global warming stuff that our
government is talking about it's all
just pork that none of it is actually
it's it's like a chernobyl on a global
warming level you know what i mean like
it's just going to be another ecological
disaster if our government does what
they want to do thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there